a big announcement today from the city
of north las vegas there's a new
commercial development center coming to
the downtown area it's going to be
located at north 5th street and lake
mead boulevard jeremy j ford showing us
what's in store for surrounding
communities
tuesday morning city leaders made an
announcement to develop 19 acres of land
into a gateway commercial plaza ward one
councilman isaac baran says the nlv
gateway is a total reinvestment in the
downtown area it's been years and coming
this is not something that's like been
something we just we just dreamed up of
it actually has taken many years to put
all the pieces in place a previous
administration
developed the downtown redevelopment
agency to do just this you know to
self-fund a transformation in the
downtown core the specific tenets have
not yet been announced but are expected
to include national retailers medical
groups and spaces for entrepreneurs a
groundbreaking is expected within the
next two months with the completion of
the project expected by 2024. jeremy j
ford live local now